WISE HOUSE.
WHEN TITLE 42 ENDS, THIS CRISIS
WILL SPIRAL MORE OUT OF CONTROL.
HERE WITH REACT, SARAH CARTER,
THE HOST OF THE LARRY ELDER SHOW
FOR THE EPIC TIMES, LARRY ELDER.
SARA, YOU HAVE BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE REPORTER FOR THIS
SHOW DOWN AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
YOU HAVE DEALT WITH THE CARTELS,
YOU HAVE DEALT WITH THE DRUG
TRAFFICKERS, YOU'VE DEALT WITH
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKERS.
EVEN YOUNG GIRLS, YOU KNOW,
THAT -- NOT EVEN OF TEENAGE
YEARS BEING RAPED ALONG THE
PATH.
DRUG CARTELS CONTROLLING EVERY
ASPECT OF THIS.
NOT ONE PERSON IS CROSSING THE
BORDER WITHOUT HAVING TO PAY
THEM.
WITH TITLE 42 GOING AWAY WHAT IS
NEXT?
>> SEAN, IT'S PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
LIKE TRIPLING DOWN ON HIS
CHAOTIC BORDER POLICY.
HE'S GOING TO MAKE IT SO FAR
WORSE.
NOT ONLY -- YOU'RE RIGHT.
NOT ONLY ARE THE CHILDREN BEING
TRAFFICKED AND THE WOMEN AND MEN
AS WELL BEING ABUSED AND TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF, BEING TURNED INTO
SLAVES, BEING USED FOR SEX, BUT
NOW AMERICANS ARE DYING.
WE CAN SEE THAT WITH WHAT
HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA.
WHAT IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH COUNTERFEIT PILLS
AND THE POISON BEING SUPPLIED BY
THE MEXICAN CARTELS AND THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY THAT IS
SENDING THESE CHEMICALS IN TO
MEXICO THAT IS ENDING UP HERE
WITH OVER 107,000 DEATHS.
IT'S ALREADY TOO LATE.
THEY NEED TO LOCK DOWN THE
BORDER.
THEY NEED TO FOLLOW THE LAW AND
THE POLICY AND THEY NEED TO GIVE
OUR BORDER PATROL AGENTS AS WELL
AS OUR DEA AND OTHER FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE TOOLS THAT THEY
NEED TO STOP THIS MADNESS.
PEOPLE ARE DYING ON BOTH SIDES.
THIS IS AN ISSUE FOR THE WHOLE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE.
NOW WE'RE UNDER DIRECT THREAT OF
BEING TARGETED BY TERRORISTS
BECAUSE OF THIS CHAOS, SEAN.
>> IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
IT'S WRONG.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT'S GOING TO
END UP HONESTLY.
THAT WAS YOUR QUESTION.
WHERE IS THIS GOING TO END UP?
IT'S GOING TO END UP IN A BAD
SPOT.
IF PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T GET
TOGETHER AND FIND A SOLUTION
QUICKLY.
>> Sean: SO LARRY, WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE AIR MARSHALLS OUT OF THE
SKY.
THAT MEANS PASSENGERS ON
COMMERCIAL AIRLINES WON'T BE
SAFE.
WE'RE GOING TO SEND THOSE GUYS
TO THE BORDER.
YOU HAVE A GOVERNOR IN
CALIFORNIA AND YOU HAVE CITIES
IN CALIFORNIA, THE STATE IS A
SANCTUARY STATE, YOU HAVE
SANCTUARY CITIES.
YOU GIVE BENEFITS TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT DON'T RESPECT
OUR LAWS, OUR SOVEREIGNTY AND
OUR BORDERS.
IF I'M AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT, I'M
HEADED TO WHERE YOU LIVE.
>> YEAH.
COME ON DOWN.
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
MARCHING ON WASHINGTON WITH
PITCH FORKS IS A TESTAMENT TO
HOW LIT THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
IS AWARE OF THIS.
IF YOU LEARNED ANYTHING FROM THE
TWITTER FILES, MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION THAT IS
UNCOMFORTABLE TO THE LEFT IS
BEING SUPPRESSED.
I WATCH BILL MELUGIN EVERY
MORNING TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER,
PROBABLY FIVE MIDDLE EL LEGAL
ALIENS, NOT EVEN THE GOT-AWAYS
AND CUT ON CNN OR MSNBC AND
THEY'RE NOT EVEN COVERING IT.
HOW MUCH IS THIS COSTING US IN
CRIME, IN HEALTHCARE, IN
EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS?
IN HOUSING BENEFITS?
WHEN GAVIN NEWSOME IS THE VOICE
OF REASON, THAT'S THE
APOCALYPSE.
HE'S MR. SANCTUARY STATE.
HE'S HIRED GEORGE GASCON THAT
JUST ORDERED HIS PROSECUTORS TO
NOT TO CHARGE ILLEGALS WITH
CRIMES FOR FEAR THEY WILL BE
PROSECUTED.
IT'S MADNESS.
>> Sean: BUT IT'S HAPPENING.
WE'RE LOSING 300 PEOPLE ON
AVERAGE A WEEK TO FENTANYL AND
OPIOID OVERDOSES.
YOU HAVE DESCRIBED SCENES THAT
REALLY ARE NOT MARISH OF YOUNG
GIRLS BEING TRAFFICKED.
GIRLS AS YOUNG AS EIGHT, 9, 10
YEARS OLD.
YOU HAVE WITNESSED AREAS WHERE
THEY HAVE BEEN RAPED.
YOU HEARD THEIR STORIES.
YOU HAVE INTERVIEWED SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE.
HOW BAD IS IT?
WHAT PART OF THIS IS THE
GOVERNMENT MISSING?
>> THEY'RE MISSING THE FACT THAT
CHILDREN ARE SUFFERING.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT ON THE DARK HORSE PODCAST.
THAT PODCAST IS SO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
REALLY HAPPENING HERE.
THESE CHILDREN ARE LITERALLY
BEING TORTURED DAY AND NIGHT.
MANY DISAPPEAR IN THE DARKNESS.
NOBODY KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENS TO
THEM.
THEY ARE KILLED, LEFT NOR DEAD
ON THE TRAIL, ON THEIR WAY TO
THE AMERICAS, ON THEIR WAY IN TO
AMERICA.
ONCE THEY GET HERE, I CAN TELL
YOU THIS.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT CLAIM TO
BE THEIR GUARDIANS ARE NOT THEIR
GUARDIANS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ABUSING THE CHILDREN HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
MANY OF THESE KIDS ARE LEFT FOR
DEAD.
WE HAD ON YOUR SHOW NOT LONG
AGO, A HUMAN SMUGGLER THAT
ADMITTED SOME OF THESE CHILDREN
ARE BEING USED FOR ORGAN
HARVESTING.
THIS IS WHAT THE GOVERNMENT DOES
NOT GET.
THEY ARE PERPETUATING ACTUALLY
THIS TYPE OF HORROR ON THESE
CHILDREN AND ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE'RE LITERALLY THE LAST LEG OF
MOVEMENT FOR THE DRUG CARTELS.
THEY'RE BASICALLY USING OUR
GOVERNMENT TO MOVE THESE
CHILDREN IN TO THE ARMS OF
PREDATORS.
EVENTUALLY THIS HAS TO STOP.
I MEAN, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CANNOT IGNORE THIS FOREVER.
BECAUSE EVENTUALLY JUST LIKE
LARRY SAID, THE PEOPLE WILL BE
MARCHING ON WASHINGTON AND
DEMANDING THAT THIS STOP.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR CHILDREN
AND THEY'RE LOSING THEIR
CHILDREN IN AMERICA TO
POISONING.
NOT TO OVERDOSE.
TO POISONING.
DIRECT POISONING FROM
COUNTERFEIT PILLS.
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT BENEFIT ARE
THE DRUG CARTELS AND THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS.
IT HAS TO STOP.
>> Sean: LARRY, WE GIVE YOU THE
LAST WORD.
>> SEAN, RIGHT AFTER BIDEN GOT
ELECTED, ABC INTERVIEWED THIS
GUY THAT CAME ACROSS THE BORDER.
SHE SAID WOULD YOU HAVE DONE
THIS IF DONALD TRUMP WAS
RE-ELECTED?
HE SAID NO.
SHE WAS SHOCKED THAT IT WAS
BECAUSE OF BIDEN'S ELECTION.
BIDEN SAID THERE WAS GOING TO BE
A SURGE ON THE BORDERS.
THAT'S WHAT HE DID BY REVERSING
THE RACIST DONALD TRUMP
POLICIES.
HE'S GOTTEN WHAT HE WA